At the time of this video’s writing, the
SCP Foundation currently contains well over
6000 items.
This organization really gets around, from
making deals with deities to containing horrors
capable of ending the world in a heartbeat.
So it’s hard to think of this secret group
ever having “Humble Beginnings”, but everyone
and everything has to start somewhere, right?
And would you believe that one of the most
powerful groups in the world all started with
a little sheaf of papers?
Of course, that’s if this particular iteration
of SCP-001 is to be believed.
That’s right, we once again return to SCP-001,
the gift that keeps on taking.
It’s a heavily contested spot, currently
held by over thirty different contradictory
anomalies and counting.
Their natures vary from things that started
the Foundation to things more than capable
of ending it, along with the rest of the world,
and everything in between.
The Scarlet King, The Gate Guardian, and the
ever-eccentric Dr. Wondertainment all exist
under this banner.
But today, we want to talk about a little
stack of paper, bound by a single staple in
the top left corner.
Who would have guessed that something this
simple would not only be pivotal in the creation
of the SCP Foundation as we know it today
but could also be one of the most dangerous
items ever discovered?
We realize this is a lot to take in.
Keeping with the SCP-001 spirit, let’s take
it all the way back to the beginning, to the
fine oak desk of the late...hmmm...uhhh, I
guess uhhhh...
Oh, we don’t have the name?
Shame.
Let’s just call him The First Administrator.
He’s the head honcho of a precursor to the
Foundation as we know it today, a rinky-dink
little organization with the thankless task
of keeping the paranormal under wraps.
We’re talking a long, long time ago here.
No lanky freaks who kill everybody who sees
their face, no gloopy sadists who can walk
through walls, no giant unkillable reptiles
with major anger issues.
This organization - let’s call them The
Precursors - was dealing with the real small
fries.
Paranoiacs reporting ghost sightings in their
garden sheds, old ladies finding the face
of Jesus in a piece of toast, abnormally large
and strangely-shaped potato chips.
Okay, maybe not that small-time, but you get
the idea.
Truly exceptional anomalies were few and far
between, until the sheaf of papers landed
on the dearly deceased Administrator’s desk.
He didn’t even know how exactly the papers
got there, but given the numbers of mostly
junk files that passed his desk every day,
he wasn’t in the business of questioning.
The words “Confidential Report on Special
Items—Classified” were printed on the
front.
This made it more interesting than 90% of
the files he read on a daily basis already,
so he turned the first page and began to read.
It was much stranger than the usual paranormal
reports that the Precursor Foundation processed.
No late-night wailing or rattling chains.
Instead, it was a surprisingly sterile report
about a bizarre and frightening anomaly: A
large, fleshy, tumor-like object fixed to
a set of metal stairs.
Inside the object is a seemingly normal living
room, but on closer inspection, all the furniture
is made out of living human tissue and flesh.
Anyone who steps inside is transformed into
more nightmarish living furniture.
The Administrator gave a nervous chuckle.
It was disturbing, sure, but Stephen King
wrote about disturbing things all the time,
and that didn’t mean that the Foundation
needed to be on the lookout for an evil clown
- Well, until SCP-993, the sinister Bobble
the Clown, would enter the Foundation’s
radar a few years later.
The Administrator put the file into his incredibly
disorganized filing cabinet, and prepared
to go home and drink bourbon until he fell
asleep.
That’s exactly when his office phone began
to ring.
When The Administrator picked up the phone,
he heard the excited voice of one of his field
agents, telling him they’d just scored the
find of the century: A giant sphere made from
living flesh with a room inside it.
Finally, an honest to god, terrifying paranormal
anomaly!
He could hardly believe what he was hearing.
He needed to grab and reread the file, just
to make sure he wasn’t going insane.
Where exactly did he put it?
He scrambled through the filing cabinet, tossing
aside the files on shed ghosts and burnt toast
Jesuses, until he found the
file marked “Confidential
Report on Special Items—Classified.”
However, when he opened the file, there was
nothing about the giant, fleshy room in there.
It must have been a completely different file
that he’d somehow missed before, because
this one was about something known as the
“Biological Motherboard.”
The document detailed pretty much exactly
what the name suggested: A large and incredibly
complex motherboard made out of biological
material like keratin and chitin.
While the motherboard would remain inactive
if kept warm, if its environment ever fell
below 35 degrees, it would begin to expand,
integrating nearby material into its mass
and attempting to copy the structure of any
biological matter it comes into contact with.
An interesting and frightening prospect, but
not what he was looking for.
He threw this new file down onto his desk
and continued to work through his chaotic
filing cabinet like a madman, searching for
the file on that frightening fleshy room that
his subordinates had
seemingly actually discovered.
But not long after, he received another phone
call from a completely different field agent.
This time, the agent was giddily telling the
Administrator about a new discovery: A huge
computer motherboard, seemingly made out of
entirely organic material!
The Administrator was floored.
He hung up the phone and slowly turned back
to the file now laying on his desk.
Those words on the cover, “Confidential
Report on Special Items—Classified”, seemed
almost mocking now.
Had all these incredible supernatural anomalies
been reported before and just lost in his
awful filing cabinet?
Was he one of the most incompetent team leaders
who’d ever walked the earth?
Just what exactly was going on here?
He sat back down at his desk, now fantasizing
about that tumbler of bourbon more than ever,
and opened the file again, hoping to read
up a little more on the impossible motherboard
that his personnel had just discovered.
But there was nothing about the Biological
Motherboard on these pages.
Instead, it described a large door inside
a factory, and the twelve rusty keys capable
of opening it.
Each of these keys would open the doorway,
but the key used would affect the reality
waiting for them on the other side.
Only the seventh and twelfth keys were safe,
opening the door with any of the others would
lead to a horrible death for anyone brave
or foolish enough to walk through.
Several days later, an anomaly matching that
exact description was discovered and contained
by the Foundation.
All of this had been an unprecedented escalation
of anomalous stakes.
Suddenly, two crucial facts clicked into place
for The Administrator: Firstly, this file
was an anomalous supernatural artifact of
its own.
Secondly, the reason it was never the same
thing was that this strange sheaf of papers
had a very specific purpose: To act as a kind
of oracle, an advanced warning system of the
next anomaly that would appear and fall into
their grasp, giving them all the knowledge
and tools they needed to safely lock these
things away.
The whole thing had been timed perfectly - what
a miracle that this immensely useful item
would appear in his office just as the anomalies
would start to come in thick and fast.
It would facilitate their mission in the coming
struggles to secure, contain, and protect
the world’s anomalies.
Hmm, there’s a certain ring to that, isn’t
there?
They were finding enough anomalies to start
classifying them numerically, starting with
the sheaf of papers themselves as SCP-001.
With another turn of the page, The Administrator
discovered a file on a magical key that can
open any lock.
Not long after, that exact key was discovered
and brought in, before being designated SCP-005.
Little by little, as more real anomalies came
in, the organization was able to expand and
bring in more personnel, as well as bringing
in more sources of funding and opening new
sites.
The rate this organization was expanding,
they couldn’t even leave management up to
one person anymore.
They needed to form a whole council to take
over management.
An O5 Council, if you will.
And it just so happened that just after that,
the sheaf of papers revealed a mythical spring
that could provide eternal health and vitality
for anyone who drinks from it.
What a perfect way to keep your management
safe in a job dealing with dangerous supernatural
entities.
And things only got stranger and more fascinating
from there.
After that came a man with a miniature version
of planet earth inside his abdomen, soon known
as SCP-007.
Next came a horrifying virus that kills and
reanimates its victims into flesh-eating zombies,
only capable of being destroyed with sufficient
trauma to the head, dubbed
SCP-008 after containment.
Another turn of the page, and not long after,
a frightening red ice was discovered in Alaska.
This mysterious substance breaks the laws
of physics, and also has the potential to
break all life on earth.
It can infect water supplies, and when a hapless
lifeform happens to drink this water, their
organs crystalize from the inside.
This became SCP-009.
Another turn of the page, and this new SCP
Foundation found a collection of six metal
collars created for human-sized necks.
When these collars are placed around the necks
of a victim, the person holding a corresponding
controller has utter domination over their
every action.
It carried on like that.
Hundreds of anomalies, and then thousands.
Years passed, the staff changed, the old guard
stepped down or died.
Every time the sheaf of papers were opened,
new astonishing premonitions of anomalies
soon to be discovered slipped through.
There were Plague Doctors who could kill with
a touch.
A giant angel with bladed wings.
A sea snail that believed he was an English
lord.
A Sculpture that would kill anything that
dared to stop looking at it.
A nightmarish fusion of a giant bovine heart
and a scorpion, capable of setting things
on fire with its venom.
Whatever would the SCP Foundation have done
without the advanced warning system provided
by the sheaf of papers?
Whatever it predicted would inevitably be
the next thing Foundation field agents would
find.
It seems like one of the few unambiguously
good SCP-001 entries out there, right?
Well, not quite.
If we have any scientists in the audience,
they’ve no doubt been gritting their teeth
and pulling their hair out in frustration.
Allow us to introduce you to a little phrase
that the latest iteration of the O5 Council
is very interested in when it comes to the
sheaf of papers: “Direction of causality.”
This whole time, we and the earlier Foundation
administrations believed that the emergence
of new anomalies led to changes in SCP-001.
But this current administration has quite
the opposite question: What if the changes
in SCP-001 were actually causing the emergence
of new anomalies?
What if every time the prior administration
opened up the sheaf of papers to take a look
at the next anomaly, before giving themselves
a pat on the back for being so well-prepared,
they were actually unleashing that very anomaly?
Could it be that what had seemed like the
most helpful item of the bunch was actually
the most dangerous of them all, releasing
new anomaly after new anomaly, blighting the
world with countless horrors?
That probably leaves you with one question:
So, which is correct?
Is it a method of seeing the future,
or manipulating
it?
And our answer is a strong...we don’t know.
But frankly, the current leadership of the
SCP Foundation sees no merit in taking that
risk.
That’s why the sheaf of papers has been
given the Keter Class designation, and is
kept under extensive and severe containment
methods, forbidding any future research into
the true nature of its anomalous abilities.
Seems a little severe, sure, but better safe
than sorry, right?
Now go check out “SCP-001 - Which is the
Real 001?” and “SCP-001 Ouroboros Cycle
- The Full Story Compilation” for more of
the fascinating, endless mystery of SCP-001!